Der Pitztaler Gletscher ist das
höchstgelegene Skigebiet Österreichs.
Die Skisaison dauert hier bis in den Mai.
Gleich drei Restaurants kümmern sich um
das leibliche Wohl der Wintersportfans,
eins auf der Gletscherspitze in fast 3.500
Metern Höhe, die anderen auf knapp 3.000.
Eines der beliebtesten Gerichte bei den
Skifahrern: der Kaiserschmarren.
Er gehört zu Österreich wie die Alpen.
Wunderbar, wie meine Großmutter
das gemacht hat.
Direkt neben den beiden Restaurants liegt
Österreichs höchstgelegene Konditorei.
Hier kümmert sich Stephanie Santeler
um die Mehlspeisen,
also auch den Kaiserschmarren.
Wir produzieren hier oben alles selber
in der Backstube,
also die ganzen Süßspeisen
in den zwei Restaurants
„Wildspitze“ und „Kristall“
und auch das „Café 3.440“
beliefern wir mit frischen Torten und
Strudel[n] mit.
Jeden Morgen werden sie mit der Gondel
zu Österreichs höchstgelegenem Kaffeehaus,
dem „Café 3.440“ hinaufgeschickt.
Es liegt noch einmal 600 Meter höher
als die Backstube.
Neben dem fantastischen Ausblick gibt
es hier noch eine besondere Gaumenfreude
– die Gletscherschneetorte.
Kokos-Ananas, sehr flockig, sehr duftig.
Wenn man die frisch nimmt,
ganz ganz zauberhaft ...
sehr, sehr ... ja, wohl ...
kann ich sehr empfehlen.
Doch das Backen in der Höhe
birgt so seine Tücken.
Das ist eben dieser Luftdruck hier.
So wie wir hier Probleme haben
auf 2.840 Metern mit Biskuitböden,
haben sie auf 3.440
mit dem Siedepunkt Probleme.
Wenn wir das wissen, dass [das] Wetter
umlässt [umschlägt], produzieren wir
immer einen Tag vorher die Biskuitböden,
weil da kann es sein, dass sie nicht
so schön locker werden und aufgehen.
Ein Kaiserschmarren ist dagegen nicht
so heikel, was die Zubereitung angeht.
Und auch die Zutaten sind äußerst simpel:
Milch, Eier, Mehl, Zucker
– mehr braucht es nicht.
Zunächst Milch und Mehl mischen,
dann die Eier trennen und das Eiweiß
mit etwas Zucker steif schlagen.
So, jetzt haben wir es schön schaumig
geschlagen,
jetzt machen wir den berühmten Test
So soll es sein.
Die restlichen Eier mit der
Mehl-Milch-Masse mischen,
dann – das ist wichtig für die luftige
Konsistenz des Kaiserschmarrens –
vorsichtig den Eischnee unterheben.
Wir hier oben am Pitztaler Gletscher
verwenden kein Mineralwasser im Teig,
wir nehmen lieber Eiweiß.
Das ... das Eiweiß macht es nicht so
trocken, den Kaiserschmarren,
der bleibt dann viel länger saftig.
So, jetzt kann man hier auch Rosinen
reinmachen.
Wir hier am Pitztaler Gletscher machen
[ihn] mit Rosinen,
man kann [ihn] aber ruhig ohne
Rosinen machen.
Wir verkaufen in der Wintersaison an
die vier Tonnen Kaiserschmarren,
das heißt an Spitzentagen brauchen
wir zwischen 150 und 200 Stück Portionen.
Fünf Minuten muss der Kaiserschmarren
auf jeder Seite backen, dann ist er fertig.
Stephanie Santeler beliefert die Restaurants
auch mit Wiener Apfelstrudel
und Palatschinken.
Von einer missglückten Palatschinke,
einem dünnen Eierkuchen,
soll der Kaiserschmarren auch seinen
Namen haben:
Denn der österreichische Kaiser Franz
Joseph liebte Süßspeisen.
War allerdings sein Lieblingsdessert,
die Palatschinke, zerrissen,
durfte die Dienerschaft den Schmarren,
also den „Unsinn“, auslöffeln.
Ein Glück – denn so wurde das
Pfannengericht als Kaiserschmarren bekannt.
So, jetzt fehlt hier oben nur noch der
Staubzucker auf dem Kaiserschmarren
und dazu servieren wir
hier oben am Pitztaler Gletscher
Apfelmus oder Preiselbeeren.
Nicht nur im Tiroler Pitztal zählt der
zerrupfte Eierkuchen
zu den beliebtesten Süßspeisen der
österreichischen Küche.